I welcome to a very special edition of
strategy session with Jonathan France
and today I'm joined by a very special
member here at the Chess Club I'm joined
by Arjun Puri who's uh you know bet just
been coming to the club all the time
goes to all the lectures all the classes
and it seems like you're a ting just
keeps going up and up and up what's your
rating these days
1,400 um yeah Arjun just keeps domain
looks like you went from like 1200 to
1400 in like a tournament no he's also
very modest yeah I just just been doing
very well on I expect his rating to keep
going up so we're going to go over two
of the games that Arjun here has played
the both of these games were played in
Monday night mayhem the first game he
played round one he played against
Darion Turner you know one of the the
forerunners in the tournament one of the
big guys I guess he's ahe's in the
eighteen nineteen hundred range I'll
also look at another game where he
played another Class B Class a player
and so have a look at some of those
games so this was Monday night mayhem so
after my Monday night class you do a
thematic tournament based on the opening
sergeant didn't get to pick his opening
and just so everybody knows it's game 45
with a five-second delay okay see you so
all these opening moves you know can be
seen in my lecture so we'll just jump to
wherever I had you start I assume I
started with this check on the board
because I always like it when his blacks
turn to move okay so here Arjun had to
make his first move and having gone to
the lecture he found the correct way to
block so that was good and already
Darren Darian did something a little bit
interesting and the main move is
actually a four but he played Knight f3
and the point of a four is to prevent
black from going through with his basic
middle game plan which is pushing his
majority on the Queen side I did mention
it briefly in the lecture so I thought
maybe he was just playing this you know
II didn't want Arjun to be all booked up
he knows our gender
sitting here in class he's really
studying it hard so I thought he just
was doing this to get Arjun out of
theory but I guess you'd say he just
said he just made a mistake he's like oh
I forgot to play a four and Arjun played
here correctly so you played a six
excellent and if the audience or Arjun
has any comments at any point feel free
to stop me and he played an interesting
move that we we did consider there's all
sorts of bishop retreats if you just
play Bishop d3 then black plays b5 and
gets on with his plan but he played this
interesting option of taking the night
did you expect that move 25% 25% all
right this is that's probably about
right and this night actually is
typically a pretty good piece for black
so we did mention the possibility of
trading the bishop for the night which
is a you know it's an interesting
strategy in here again all the bishop
retreats any Bishop d3 is a domain move
and yeah you allow b5 but that you know
he chose the variation not me so instead
he took and again here you can play a
four move that kind of surprised me
though Queen c2 which i think is a bit
slow I think if you're applying in your
you know get just trading the bishop
with check you want to you know get
something in return for your time so
probably a four here is to be
recommended but he played Queen c2 and
then here it was interesting for me
because I thought you would play b5 but
you castled and I was trying to figure
out which is more accurate maybe
castling is more accurate I forgot to
play be fine you forgot to play b5
because I was wondering if you were
saying to white you don't even have time
you're you know you played Queen c2 now
you don't even have time for a move like
this because I don't know maybe you're
you're already ready to strike with a
move like f5 or something
I forgot to bet you could play a four I
thought that he could only play it after
I played night up to d7 okay interesting
and yes I know but this might even be
more accurate I don't know cuz you know
a 5u is wasting some time you might be
able to get f5 and and attack the center
right away so Darien was not interested
in stopping it so he decided could just
cancel and now you did do it b5 I guess
I remembered all right good you
remembered your own game you remember to
play b5 I didn't remember I remembered
it okay um
a4 okay so if you you know don't want to
let him open up the file you have to
play a move like b4 and okay it does
force this night to a sort of awkward
square but perhaps in the future you'll
be able to make use of some of the light
squares maybe even get that Knight to c4
or maybe the extra night maybe the other
night to c4 and then I think here there
was also another interesting moments you
went here which which kind of surprised
me so I kind of wanted to talk about
this position and I guess the way I'm
looking at it is I still want to think
about what I want to do on the Queen
side so I guess I'm still in the future
I'm trying to play the moves like c4 as
black and maybe I can get my knight here
so I thought perhaps that would have you
know been a little more natural to put
your upon here on a5 and with the idea
of putting the Bishop over on a6 I
didn't really want to weaken the light
squares too much okay but you do have a
light spread bishop and he doesn't
so let's but he has two knights they can
get into holes mm-hmm I guess I should
play d5 mm-hmm yes then and then also if
you control c4 you might be able to push
your C pawn and then your knight gets to
c5 and okay you know sometimes the night
it's always sometimes a question
sometimes it is better than f6 sometimes
it's better on d7 sometimes it's tough
the good thing about having it on f6
though if we look at at the plus side is
it's really hard for him to ever push a
five because now is deep on his hanging
so in a lot of lines now it's just
harder for him to push in the center so
that's that's the good side
ever considered that good side never
consider that good side I couldn't
figure out anything else to do easy just
played it were you intending then just
to develop the bishop out this way or
maybe rakul rook e8 yeah these are all
quite normal moves so okay we'll see how
the game went um Knight d2 so this yeah
this is a bit too much retreating um
it's going to c4 yeah okay so he's
what's going to c4 it's all planned out
okay mm-hmm
you have these sorts of ideas as we we
saw Aronian do against Caruana alright
which is yeah it's typically pretty
dangerous so here you put your queen on
e7 I didn't know which was better the
queen of the rook and here's something
should go to the e-file maybe both maybe
both okay
and I think that's what you did in the
game right you put both on there uh but
now dear Darian is already shaking his
head yeah rook e1 was not a good move
and we'll get the the rest of the
audience involved what's what's the move
here for for black origin yeah so this
was this was missed in the game you
didn't play this move our Jin oh yeah
it's a pin uh yeah that's just a clean
pond so that would have just been really
good for you yeah so a missed
opportunity but you did move your knight
so you thought about moving the night
you just use didn't think about taking
the pawn and so Darian got away with one
yeah so so Darian is saying he never
really wanted to play e5 mostly because
it's not Darian style and he was more
focused on trying to get the moves b3
and Bishop b2 in just to contest the the
long diagonal which is interesting and
okay but yeah you did you didn't miss a
little opportunity there
so okay he took you took back excellent
and now the night gets to go to c4 and
how did you have al you ate the position
at this point I thought it was a little
better that he was living better mmm yes
nice pretty good but I wish upon the one
dad
in pretty soon you could have played
your really really good move here on
this move but you waited a turn
oh wait 54 um
yeah you'll see so we'll show the
audience in this position I mean he
could he could play the right move in
this position but but he waited one turn
and Aryan could have avoided it with
what's coming with Bishop d2 but what
move did Arjen play in this position he
has a really clever move do you know
what Arjun played I don't know you don't
know stuff that was like magnification
eight days ago
does anyone see just a really clever
move that black can play
h4 Queen h4 okay this is interesting
because yeah you're attacking the rook
so I'm going to move this I'll just go
here okay
pish-posh - it looks dangerous
that does look pretty dangerous hmm yeah
I guess maybe I have to go all the way
here oh wait after I think I found
something
can you found something in this one you
know after King H won their stuff - rook
rook f1 okay then you know worried about
this h3 oh yeah then then the after yes
yes it was like it so yeah perhaps in
this position I do have to stop that and
you did play this a few moves later this
this check which is a big part of the
Benoni so you remember to do it which
was good but Masari in this position
Arjun played another fantastic move do
you remember now
there's that six I saw the notation just
about five yeah Bishop f5 just
threatening to win the pond and so now
you now you see that there's a pen yeah
you only see it like when it's like
cooler when it just winds upon you
didn't see it but now that it's like
cooler and it acts upon in a really
funny way now you see it so white
basically has to go back and then you
really should just leave your fish up
there he's sort of all tied up and the
pin is not going away but you played I
don't even know do you check now yeah
you checked okay so that was good
and this always is a big part of the
benoni playing Bishop to d4 as black so
very good and now you missed a chance
you you were treated your bishop I know
I played there I want to play f5 you
played there so you could play out five
what which I think isn't itself a good
idea but perhaps your best bet was even
to go Queen h4 so very similar to what
was was just mentioned yes and in this
case you can't even move the bishop to
connect the rooks so it would be an even
improved version of that other
conversion so perhaps the continuation
will go like this now you can attack the
if he blocks you can even just drop back
and black just has full command of this
position and now your idea of f5 is
really good you could double on the
e-file first or just play a 5 so
something like this also would just been
tremendous for black in this position
that this doesn't work ok sorry but in
this position Knight f3 does it there's
a tactic mm-hmm-hmm is it just like
similar to I just have to go back could
it be
or is it like I take here something like
hoof clever move alright
only only there were a way to figure it
out oh you can take the rook apparently
oh this is good it doesn't even mess up
the screen so people at home don't know
if we're cheating or not so that's
that's good news and then now you just
take here yeah well I don't see why it's
so good it'll do excited and okay so
something like this would have also been
tremendous for black but also yeah
audience at home they'll never know for
cheating somehow somehow it didn't mess
it up today okay we'll turn it off
though okay so that all this would have
been possible slide I don't think Bishop
d7 was necessarily the best move here I
think he could have kept it there but
playing at five I think is definitely
right and called for in this type of
position so now he gets a move so he
goes right back to c4 that's that's
where he wants to be that's where he
goes I didn't talk about a repetition
there you didn't think about a
repetition err
you didn't think you should go here and
then but now in this position you can
play here me if I think that's a
previous move and I can't find it I
probably won't find it see maybe if you
would have repeated though you have had
time to figure it out then I wouldn't
and I was a waste of time yes depends on
how long you think about it I guess uh
okay yes so I like it yeah and that's
the good thing about origin - you know
he's four hundred points lower rated or
so and he's thinking about winning and
it was also cool while watching this
there was a play rated 2350 it was in
the tournament you could see at manesis
like he's so super concentrated and he's
playing Mario Roper he's like oh yeah
you know and then I look over and it's
argent doing the same thing you know
he's just like so focused so determined
and that's one of the things that I
think people are so afraid to play you
because you're always like you're
determined to win it doesn't matter what
they're rated and I think that just
makes you you know a really difficult
competitor to play with because you know
I see everybody else and they're just
kind of like you know talking and like
playing you know Arjun Arjun Zahra win
if I'm like playing like a really high
rated player I just go for a draw from
the one does that work out for you yeah
usually not
you ever try to beat really high rated
players remove one sometimes sometimes
does that work out better or same result
slightly better slightly better hmm all
right yeah and yeah normally when you're
just thinking about a draw it just
doesn't work out but you know when arch
is really determined to win he's very
strong and hard to beat so here it's
it's black to move and let's see as you
stated you wanted to do f5 okay I think
that's that's very logical in the
position and I guess white has to push
mm-hmm you have to play Knight to c4 so
you would be able to play e5 and in the
case of f5 I thought I sitter this for a
long time and I thought that is passed
pawns would just pay too much of
weakness
okay so you think his best ones are
gonna be a weakness okay excellent
ah and here you took which you almost
always have to take this and then here
Darian played a move that is normally
really good for white but it wasn't the
case in this exact position here you
played the move d6 much better was just
taking on e5 and normally this is you
know a good move I mean white wants to
play the move d6 even you know in most
positions but here it doesn't quite work
and Arjun could have played a really
nice combination here I think in the
game you just moved your your
cooperative but I'll ask the audience to
what do you think what could Arjun do
there's a little a couple moves if you
find a couple moves in a row then okay
you get a good really good position I
think first we replaced okay what's the
first move create four it looks like
yeah Queen h4 y a good thing normally
like I origins out there in the audience
and he's the only one answering the
question so it's it's even easier when
you're right here okay so he protects
and I mean there's a lot of different
ways but even just a simple move like
this puts a lot of pressure on white and
you have all sorts of ideas of attacking
this pond you can go here here and you
have all sorts of attacking ideas that
it's already really hard for for white
to think about defending a position like
this so this you know this is really
active plans might have really worked
out for you but you decided you just go
to g7 which is safe enough it's
controlled d5 but perhaps again another
missed opportunity to get a tremendous
positional I didn't think that his past
pounds would be too strong in that
position
okay we're hoping to like pick up his
pawns I was hoping soon I was hoping
that
I figure a way to break into his
position and get my works behind his
pawns okay yeah I think that's that's
very sensible but it's been oh nice also
you should attack don't attack
oh yeah it's it's double-edged yeah when
you when you play back on the bodoni you
attack as well it's just everybody
attacks everybody especially you know if
white isn't attacking you and you don't
have to defend very often it is black
that is the one that gets to be the
aggressor okay you said the opposite
yesterday oh well when white plays well
see sometimes you know white doesn't
attack you and play the most critical
whatever so alright takes all right
takes how should he take back now this
this is a question the audience can
answer how should we take back all right
good all right we got to make sure
everyone in the audience is on the same
page here I guess it was a tough
question because okay see you doubled
here so all this was normal and then
somewhere around here darienne's like
hey hey stop watching that game come
watch my game it's like this is so
incredible like what's going on
I was very complicated and yeah and yeah
this is the second offer to draw okay
and you declined okay all right I love
it I love it umm yes what is he gonna do
yeah I miss this you missed this move
and I think you traded I suppose maybe
you don't have to trade maybe you can do
something else well I didn't find
anything else didn't see anything else
yeah you have to keep the c5 fun okay
but even if he takes your rook can you
take back with a queen you're you're
still defending yeah I thought it was
work I thought I should just um try to
get my King active or something cuz you
are you're helping out the rook on b1
a little bit yeah and now his bishop is
that probably the best piece
yeah the bishop is quite nicest it's
really brain your face any Queen movie
yeah alright but here
how would you Arjun you in here which is
interesting why did you play this move
stop Quincy for Trek but I missed Queen
takes e5 mm-hmm
but that wasn't played also why didn't
you take those soon I assume clean b3
clean up too or maybe do you have any
active rules mm-hmm yeah you just keep
taking stuff and yeah but I thought
nobody takes nobody in the banila right
so yeah yeah right what's just true so
yeah so Darian knew that and you finally
got to play your move b3 so any second
now he's gonna fianchetto winners so
what do you got okay
you got be free and now the C pawn is is
attacked um yeah I think I'm here okay
yeah you're okay
f6 15 f6 but it drops a pocket so I
don't like it anymore
it's this is a tricky yes well we're
playing we're hoping oh yeah that's what
we're hoping for
so yeah Quentin's apollomon can you just
take this what's your big threat what's
your big blur I said clean d5 burdens
upon 25 thorns upon note for black
instead of Queen of 6
yeah so that's yeah I think I think
that's the right move
all right he attacked your queen you
don't know hmm yeah right so here's his
little tactic that I assume works I
assume I doesn't have any like counter
checks and but you never know you know
sometimes you might be able to check you
and defend his rook somehow but that's a
little trick we're playing for so rook
d1 yeah a white wind if I owned like
with a 56 mm-hmm in this way if we pass
yeah there's like Quincy for King a
favorite prep sex wins
all right what's your line again 24 okay
and then I go some dark square which is
kind of scary
all right there
I'm not trying to do any more huh yeah
nobody nobody could ever solve the
problems all right it's platypus I mean
it wait wait to play and you should just
go here and ignore everything and hope
to win all right so yeah parently black
is is winning after this oh yeah
that so this is a real threat and yeah
tricky one that says you know that's
moved so okay so you played the best
move now you ain't here I suppose also I
mean you could consider going here just
so that if he takes your pawn you take
his bomb
yeah with 24 I was playing for a draw
okay Queenie for playing for a draw uh
no Mia cuz II just he just takes us now
novice I was thinking that he would take
the Queen and then like try to grab my
pawns well I hope to grab his and I know
that'll matter on the Kings side that I
can drop down and every now and then you
take this pawn when he's not looking
no I was thinking about Bishop e6 which
takes Peter Bishop a4 I'm letting him
grab all my pawns and try to me Hey
yes I mean yeah those that was an
interesting option taking but I think
this is just a safe pawn to grab and
yeah I think it's just completely equal
now mmm you thought rook c8 okay so this
wasn't played in the game I assume
that's different things I can do I you
know I can come in here I can go back to
safety
you know it's
yes there's also one of an interesting
did you consider this move oh no and you
you gotta have some more tricks you're
playing for tricks okay let's see oh you
made a serious threat yeah I think
second Queen c4 there you expecting
Queen c4 yeah and trying to make him
trying to make me sack and then like
play for like 4 no I was expecting like
him to know him to take him to take your
specking him to take yeah and then like
this this line here you're gonna move
and he's gonna take
I thought his clean is on teeth worth
the entire time no honey no yeah 24 I
thought about taking and then like on
pawn takes Bishop a4 d7 mmhmm yeah
something like this is going after d7
I'm not sure what's going to happen
mm-hmm my 20 now I thought that I could
try and draw 3 verse 2 but it too has
the bishop has the extra yeah F here
here and yeah I don't think your you
gonna push all these guys in this
position no after this after this rook
c8 yeah at least and at least I think I
don't have time to protect all my stuff
and still no a your queen
I was thinking I think I was thinking
about that
mmm but if I but otherwise I'm coming up
with it right now but yeah the your
pawns better between where else you're
you're down a bishop go to upon though
two pawns
you know you know bishops were three
boys three pawns of some kind more than
a bishop though all right okay so he
took will get back to the game here he
made a threat he saw it he didn't just
trade the Queen's know if you would have
known he was gonna like Sakas pieces you
should have traded Queens
alright so we're not doing I mean I
still think this is just completely
equal now you can got a little active
I'd probably would've played Bishop d7
but this is probably fine
made a little left alright he's not
gonna get back rank checkmated very good
I wouldn't have anyway you want to I
still have 3 6 + f7 even a second one g8
mm-hmm okay so you're attacked upon and
then somewhere around here so now it's
actually it's getting a little dangerous
for your Kings it's a little bit
dangerous yeah cuz here you played this
move
probably it's already so dangerous that
you should take the draw here oh like
what what you did not for a draw here
yeah but similar to the game that's like
this takes G - yeah I think you should
have just gone here and gone for the
draw and this is going to be sort of
what happens in the game and if if King
h2 then just Queen e5 and then he's
eventually gonna have to take it but
just to give one line if here you know
you can just keep checking with your
queen you can take the rook and then
make white try to draw with you so you
could have made him try to find all this
girl like then I think I'm winning
if you can't forget it Ross mm-hmm but
objectively it should be a draw but here
I think it's now is now that you had the
really crushing double X clam is that
this move yeah so we'll let the audience
try to see white actually has a winning
move here it's it's quite brutal and not
very easy to see someone will give the
audience a chance
and then when they can't figure it out
we'll just ask our doom
you haven't figured out okay you didn't
analyze this with a computer after your
game yeah okay I don't know my notation
was mm-hmm I can send it to you
tactical challenge number nine number 14
you probably know what I'm up to more
than I do
mmm-hmm in Queen d4 is definitely a part
of it the truly amazing move that I can
actually play in this position is is the
very ruthless d7 which I mean it's just
amazing
did you know it's like what what's that
all about well okay so if we take wait
actually can play boy Queen d4 that's a
part of it
yes you might actually have so many
threats and the computer wants to take
this and the point is similar yeah so
pointy 4 is a part of it wants to go
here and here wants to go here like
there's so many threats that it says
White is now completely winning I assume
neither of you saw t7 because it's it's
not an easy move to see and you know
even working it out with the computer
there's all sorts of crazy variations
that we could go into it's kind of very
humid moving yeah yeah so you didn't
interesting to it d7 you would have been
like the hero you'd be up here right now
you played d7
all right but instead you took here
which is now again just a draw and then
I think here yeah you just went in for
it now so similar to that line yet you
take care now it should be a draw and I
like that at first even take it
good then eventually though you will be
forced to take it only move you can't go
back to the first ring because when you
take the road take a trick okay
and so okay black or white that's the
show that he can draw this position
buddy I'll have an easy draw mmm do you
think you should play something else
here I think you've met page six but I
saw that he just get back into it with
clean you three it looks like we need
three yeah yeah can we can I really
really yeah I can go get mated yeah I
have to go back and then you would go
here yeah oh inside also would have just
been a drop um in the game okay it was
and I thought about King age six in
which so they repeated uh like would
after before f-16 age six over yeah
quintet's ei Queen g1 gets another draw
okay see the White has to see the
tactics way to us to see the tactics he
coulda tested him Michael doe but I
don't want to take the risk risk of it
what you don't want to take the risk
that he might wonder cuz then you would
have won that's the risk you weren't
willing to take um yes actually I mean
it was a spectacular game it was
obviously very very complicated so it's
actually yes it was a good game how do
you feel about that game I upset you
didn't win yeah no okay so I thought
yeah that was a really complicated game
really well thought and now II you got
you know you got your half point you're
going in now to the second round which
was played just last night and you're
playing Danny Machuca and also what I
like about Arjun is you just said to me
can i play Danny Machuca so I'm like
sure ah you know some people would have
been like wait there's a 100 rated
player in the tournament can I
can't play that person but not RJ okay I
want to play the top two people and we
were going to try to show a game that
like he lost for this lecture but that's
too hard because he doesn't lose so
here's a game he played against Danny
you do moose yeah like you you sometimes
lose chess games yeah oh I've never seen
it so I wouldn't know you win a lot I
thought you have seen it probably after
I wasn't called oh show me classic yeah
you lost some games in that tournament
yeah Oh some pretty good people uh okay
so this is his game against Danny
Machuca one of our own Danny works here
our gin again the opening was forced so
we'll jump through it and today it was
the this special line and here Danny has
the choice so it's black to move and he
chose something like I'm purpose to make
sure that there was no Theory allowed
yeah i'm purpose I thought he forgot -
mhm
well he didn't go to the class RG went
to the class and so Danny's like yeah
I'm not doing any theory you know I'm
gonna play just some random moves well
it feels like I think he just assumed b6
was not theoretical oh and now you're on
your own it doesn't look like the
article it looks like a six in theory
and yeah there's I mean there's so many
lines in this position the main move
being b5 so we talked about this also
popular as a six like this this is a
move this is everything to move and this
has been played by a few grandmasters so
it's it's okay one more last night and
one more and Danny um see you castled
which i think is correct and Danny again
did something he played Knight F to d7
and I asked him why he's like well
because it's the funniest the main line
in this variation is to put the bishop
on a six I mean that's why you played b6
and we can just show a few moves here
they trade and okay at some point you
should buy a six some b5 but
Danny did that but like really slowly
okay and you get a position like this
where you can even do this really cool
maneuver we swing the rooks over so
something like this is the way black
typically plays these positions and he
did actually mention the possibility of
doing this because he's like yeah but
then it would be a Machuca rook and I
didn't want you to make fun of me when I
play the Machuca Brooke and I lose so
Danny actually did consider something
like this but he's like you know why he
calls in the trucco well I call it the
Machuca rook but normally yeah but
normally you have like he the first game
Danny ever played like when he came to
the club for the first time I played a
game in the Knights and he lost and he
let you know his opponent take a bishop
on e7 so his rook ended up like that in
the corner and in that position it was a
very very bad rook sometimes that's okay
hmm so but it's 22 he shows me all these
examples I'm like show me one example
where the Machuca Brook is good he shows
me all these drawers he's like but okay
I mean sometimes it is fine as in here
because you're swinging the work over
but I just called him to arrest the
first game I ever saw him play he ended
up like this and it was a case where it
happened to be a bad example okay so
we'll go back and see what he actually
played in the game he played the funny
Knight F to d7 I thought I was recalling
our last whole clincher right when this
was the thing but yes completely
different yeah cuz Weiss got all his
pieces out in castled and it's a
completely different position
but I feel like this is just the wrong
plan he's gonna put his night here on e5
which is gonna allow white to trade so I
do like your move you went here getting
more control over he five and
threatening the backward pawn when the
guy tied to the penalty mm-hmm yeah yeah
you're turning the d6 pawn but I think
just this plan in general you know and
allowing you know wait to get the past
pawn sort of the kramnik D pawn he loves
to have those that passed on I think is
in general it's just a mistake this is
already very good for white just
positionally and it is always a question
here to of whether or not he should
actually trade the dark squared bishop
and the benoni is sort of funny because
normally you know like if this is a
dragon you're like oh I've never given
away that Bishop but in the benoni
sometimes it's black that can exploit
the dark squares and so often you will
want to do this trade and I was playing
a player once where it was a similar
position where they allowed something
like this and in that game which was
obviously completely different than this
he took with a pawn and it was wrong he
was supposed to trade the dark squared
Bishop first and even though it's a long
ways away there are some dark squares
that you know maybe his knight can go to
and something like that so it is always
a question I don't think in this
particular position it's particularly
wrong to take what the pond but I think
in general the strategy of giving white
a passed pawn is just incorrect for
black I was more afraid of this one than
the bishop takes mmm you thought you'd
be able to exploit the dark squares no I
thought that yeah cuz my Queens good on
h6 cuz your Queens good on h6 yeah so
the bishop so he took and then I like
what you did here so I mean obviously
you have to make a decision and you
stayed on the bishops natural diagonal
which i think is good I think if you go
back to g3 you might be shut out of the
game for a while
so I like this you win here and I
probably still play Bishop a6 or I just
like a six and try to play b5 or
something but okay is maneuvering his
Knight I guess he's going to have six
and okay from f6 I think he was thinking
of blockading so he's gonna do some some
triangulation with a knight
triangulation though so ok see played
here and I think yeah your intention is
to trade the dark spread bishops and it
as always I you know I it's always a
thing is it's strange sometimes it is
black that wants to trade the dark
squared Bishop you know so I think I
would only do this you're going to do
this in a second I think I would only
make that trade if I was like
checkmating or something but look at the
game
in this position if fr was played but I
don't think I for either
it was plate so to move it is a move
here I feel like you just positionally
you have a big advantage and so if
you're thinking about what Danny's gonna
do next dine me I don't know what he's
going to do and so when you play a four
you are drastically changing the nature
of the position so you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't do anything here
yeah just like Network ad one I think
that's a fine move I mean just a four
just like any any random move that
doesn't really change anything cuz I
what's Danny gonna do I'm curious
he's just going to wait for me to do
something yes I think a Yuko he could
have waited a little bit and see how
he's gonna develop f3 I considered it
but my plan was to trade the dark for a
bishops and then my lunch my bishops
really bad okay and sure you're thinking
of attacking checkmate now I was
thinking about supporting you for okay
you're doing it for you for very
interesting very interesting
f4 uh also of course this does liberate
his bishop what but I was trying to
trade it off you're planning on trading
and obviously weren't weren't you
worried so I wonder too if he had played
rook e8 here which you didn't do he went
there because she's funnier he almost
played 48 he almost turned she's room
yeah almost this is rook yeah uh were
you just gonna push or something there I
was going to treat the hips you're still
gonna go in for this and if he went
every ship's gonna reach six at least
missions good on a Jeep oh yeah mm-hmm
anyone in d5 yeah I just feel like I
mean f4 is obviously back if we just
back up to I think f4 is obviously gonna
happen at some point I probably would
have waited forever
um but he went here obviously because
it's funnier
yeah but he's gonna blockade on e5 and
if he does manage to successfully
blockade I mean it's you know might
actually end up being good for him
because here you wanted to trade but
then what ends up happening if we'll
just go forward a couple moves here so
you traded the dark squared bishop s--
but suddenly it's actually black i think
that gets a really good piece on a dark
square so i don't i don't particularly
like this trading of that he's trying to
what the light squares in this case
mm-hmm and okay so i think in an ideal
world too you know he would trade these
these two people and have a good night
where's bad bishop scenario they need to
be very very happy yeah
yeah suddenly i think I like black now
cuz it looks like he's gonna be able to
blockade both of the pawns and I don't
need five is really good yeah I don't
know what you're gonna do about that
night did you not mind that night there
I was thinking about in a night maneuver
to get rid of it okay
what were you how are you gonna do that
we're gonna get this Knight to c4
somehow get it to d3 so now you're gonna
get it to d3 somehow oh did you actually
have a plan like 92 94 Bishop C to 93
that wastes a lot of time dish up
somewhere in here yeah yeah so let's see
what happened b3 we did you think he was
threatening this cuz I I'm pretty sure
can't you just take it thanks
and yeah Danny told me he's like yeah I
wasn't even thinking about c4 yeah I
guess that's the move which is kind of
strange too because I think he generally
does want to push those those pawns but
here it just blunders opponent and I
mean in this trade would make it even
worse because now you get that really
pesky made out of there what so here I
think tactical you could have you know
maybe I don't think he was gonna play it
cuz he told me I wasn't even thinking
about that he's like b3 I didn't know
that was all about but I assumed it was
just a stop see for what okay now he
went here very aggressive so he's
playing black and he puts his queen over
there on h4 that's what you should have
done that's where you said mm-hm that's
why I told you that it's the options of
what happen really should be mmhmm yeah
I think it was here is this this way
yeah yeah wasn't sure she thought you
were worse here which I I think you're
worse right what and it looks like he's
threatening to start to come in here and
then these the sec becomes a real threat
maybe like that stuff
yeah so you played a good move you
didn't let the Queen in and regarding h3
against potential sacrifices for their
yeah you weren't threatening regret for
and then you didn't play it you played
something else so here I don't know you
went you uh in this position you play
Queen here which I didn't really like
and I was talking at in the post-mortem
with Danny before you know we looked at
this with an engine or anything I was I
said why here why don't you like playing
rook up for why would you want to trade
the Queen's is white and Danny thought
that this was good he's like oh yeah you
trade the Queen's and but I didn't I
didn't particularly like it did you
consider rook out for I do and then what
is there something you didn't like about
it no no there's nothing I don't like
about the need for them okay who's who's
King do you think it's safer yeah
u-kiss skiing is safer what it's tough
question I guess I don't know I think me
maybe white is better by let you know
this what one one mill upon Jake you're
one mill upon better no I think
some three or four mill ponds better
okay
so let's let's check the second thing d
trust Fritz are doing it to go get a
serious engine I don't trust anything
you trust any of them
yeah all right so yeah Fritz it doesn't
like it this is now you're a little bit
worse so that's like one half point yeah
one have fun it wants you to go here so
I wonder what what about here zero zero
zero but it doesn't tell us the mill
opens so we can't we can't really be
sure um all right I didn't I didn't
particularly like it for it's doesn't
particularly like it Dani liked it Arjun
liked it um okay say ASIC so here
finally he's getting his queen side play
together
so the typical move a4 very good
and now after have six you know his
favorite move so that's good
just least favorite in Mike's least
favorite I know I didn't I wonder if
that's why you know that's why he likes
it because everyone says don't play that
move over then he loves it no his King
should be here because he always plays
f6 King up side but in every game I
don't think is King ever goes there
though like like 20 moves later okay
good yeah I hope the King goes here cuz
I otherwise it wouldn't be a Machuca
game um and now a funny thing happened
like you went here and then soon the a
file opened up and then you rook wasn't
on the a file and then he took the a
file yeah so that wasn't good and he
dropped in exchange so oh yeah this
happened and then since your rip was off
the a file he went to the a file and now
the position is quite good for black
yeah I thought I was worth here mm-hmm
yeah I D I think you're just just worse
here so at least a hundred mill ponds at
least 100 mill upon's how many sent upon
this is that uh G for this this I just
didn't understand I mean what was what
was this move all about this just looks
like yours gets bad the queenside so I
have to get play on the kingside say we
thought g4 g5 no I was thinking that if
he got his work on two six of rep a3 I
play d5 okay see that if he went here
position you play this move the only
move I didn't like was age six you
didn't like itch six here like no
instead of rock a3 said overpay three
what if it stops it I wonder if I
shouldn't can stop this though hmm let's
say don't play what it Danny played
Danny played c4 which I think also it's
a interesting move so if here here I
mean should I even stop it
I can always I can play here this is one
interesting option
don't the position still tricky ever
they gotta make sure what I'm doing here
if only like our gym or in the audience
I can ask them okay um okay yeah but
it's like just ignores everything looks
like up defense just defend the pawn it
says lack is you know a quarter of a
minute a quarter pun yes that's that's
pretty serious
um hmm so that would have been
interesting but I think the way it turns
out is this just weekend mr. King a lot
and you get into trouble
yeah and maybe could play g5 and try to
like set to pieces for working pawn okay
so yeah if he plays g5 here yeah work up
to you're gonna play work f2 what this
one
I mean seems fine for black right yes
again bish
well now I might still do what he's like
we're doing the game or he might just
blows ropes or who knows more because
what a dandy Machuca would do I would be
worried that sometimes this this would
happen
eighth floor doesn't look good for black
though and I wouldn't look be good on me
before I don't think yeah but you know
none yeah not if I could just teleport
there I mean this but here you're gonna
take it cuz I know you you're gonna take
it right I can't take it so fast
I play Negi to first you play 92 first
and more sensible oh okay uh but in the
game Danny just he got on with a he's
gonna make a pass her over there and
then I was wondering if the game okay
you took I was I was thinking maybe he
would try this move or some other move
like this which I thought worked out but
you'll have to tell me here okay
yeah the problem is you can't put a rook
on f3 to defend the night
if you're willing second exchange I'm
willing to accept so mm-hmm
you know it's not worth it hmm also
rotate three there's like there's a lot
of moves I can play now that would be
really good so I thought he could try
something like that
instead he just took back and now you
went here what was the reason behind
this move I guess you just want to be
able to go to e2 so I don't remember you
want to go to go to e3 e3 okay cuz he
did drop down yeah and now I'm in
mistake no you made a mistake negative
three and this actually is a funny
position so this is the the most
critical position in all the games so we
will go to the audience was what you
guys think the best move is and I think
the answer will actually surprise you
there's an even better move it doesn't
look like Knight f3 then hmm
so yeah in the game rook a to
okay - which is one of the lines that
does win
the point is if here Oscar also remember
exactly why there's some you know crazy
tactic does anybody see it both these
removes just blues look like work be is
something okay so this looks pretty good
this looks pretty good too and I mean
yeah if here it's even funnier you can
take this one yeah if you take check and
you take the rope and everything falls
apart so there's all sorts of things so
he was kind of looking at rook a - so he
spent a lot of time here but the
computer's favorite move is rook here
yeah so you you can't oh no I think I
think I did look at this yesterday
remember the computer someone like Drogo
three mm-hmm and then yeah if here you
just go here and it's like Black's
winning by a lot mm-hmm
so this all sort of been interesting
I was act as after I played might be
when I was trying to look relaxed so you
wouldn't see native three and computer
doesn't like it it's like now is equal
black went from winning until you cool
yeah um so yeah you lose an exchange but
this is really funny this position is
great because you went here and where's
this Rick though yeah it has to go to f4
I mean that it's just really funny that
you have all of these squares under
control you have the entire third rank
so he had to put his rook here I did ask
him if he was like thinking about
counter sacking me exchange just does
not having a rook on f4 but he's like no
I didn't think about that
so yeah k12 f4 and now again I think he
made a mistake so this is sort of a
planning exercise for the audience and
we're sort of low on time so that you
guys if you want to pause your video
d1 this of d1 yeah that looks good for
Platt anyway what's what's the point if
best 3 try to win that D change you're
gonna put your Bishop here and win back
the exchange yeah how you gonna do that
I can't eat drink but I always had g5
and then like I'm kind of a [ __ ] then
will you find life when you finally
attack it with your name cuz here uh
yeah we actually should do let's see if
another is play here Oh in 92 I did that
next move
yeah and then it was one move to solo
because if here and he had he would have
to take this you know you'd have to do
something like this and okay yes
efficient - yeah looks crushed now
blending sorry in the game you went here
which gives them some time to do some
stuff so after this now you're going for
it but it's a little bit different
because he already has this move so yeah
I guess you're worried about wrote a
three which is a big threat so you don't
quite have time to play 92 so the
aggression would have been better and
they keep the work bottled up mm-hmm and
yeah I mean you had to be quick to with
attacking yet it was hard to see to that
he gets so much active play you waste
just one turn and suddenly again he's
super active so again the tables are in
blacks favor here you defended your
night very good and yeah here he went he
finally did it so now I know Danny
masuka's playing black this is an
authentic Machuca game I mean also you
could consider a move like h5 I thought
you know that might be a little bit
stronger but uh yeah he runs his King
all the way in so we'll get to the the
next critical point and then at some
point he just took this I was confused
out of computation by yeah I think h5 is
a much better move and it's similar to
what he did maybe he wants to play King
and five first yeah thinking is just
trying to hit on the Queen side what's
king but yeah you think he could at
least get his king just a little bit
closer to before he did something I
think this just wanders in exchange oh
so I don't see any direct way for black
to exploit this and
yet again it feels like now it's just
you know Josh again yeah
and now eight four finally makes sense
um it for for white in with disposition
no like no not not there but like
eventually eventually I make sense not
here but eventually okay don't just tell
me when you tax your stuff you defend
the stuff including the e3 or g3 makes
sense
mmm you know he goes here so okay he's
really he's playing for the win it's
getting complicated here so you take all
right audience just got a lot higher
rated um yes this is really complicated
because you giving this passer also it's
not it's king is active yeah um and yeah
it should be this also was a nice move
was really tricky I hadn't seen it until
we played this takes extreme mmm-hmm I
thought about it but I didn't know
saying Bishop until I he played it
mm-hmm
so yeah so here you can't take on e4
either way and it was tricky booth so
you went way over there you know you
took this yeah I can go swing for the
trough you're playing for a drop your
palm I didn't know what to do you didn't
know what to do yeah you know just do
you guys have time throw away your half
playing for a win what does that even
mean
playing for a draw wait um playing for a
win and a draw at the same time or yeah
yeah at the same time okay so you
defended a I mean your opponent G for
this I didn't think that was a mistake
but it says question mm-hmm yeah I
didn't I didn't particularly like this
move g4 I thought it was just trying to
draw now cuz I think you can put your
rope anywhere back here so this isn't
the game I thought if you put your rook
back here you know something like this
and you are in time
to see six you're trying to make me in
one move Oh mm-hmm
so yeah that doesn't quite work I'm
sorry let's see your line interesting
idea okay take the epon check yes sort
of yeah things are falling apart
that's dry still strong wish I was black
I'm trying to listen maybe um
in the game you went here which I think
yeah you were worried about this this
pawn yeah but now I'm a pawn temporarily
but I know yeah darn uh okay so you have
a nice blockade and again it should be
drawn and then eventually Danny just
blunders like big-time which is very
unusual how much time did you guys have
in this he had about two minutes I'd
like ten okay all right so here you took
takes okay it's very very drawn here
he's super blenders yeah the admin and a
half though all right how do you blunder
in this position one way there's more
than one way well there's only a couple
though yeah so see can the audience
blunder the way Danny Machuca did in
this position what's bad you sure well
nobody else is raising my hand that's a
problem you're the only one in the
audience that ever raises your hand so
like they didn't been there I can never
call on them like I need you in the
audience all right what what did you
play here Arjun o g8 rook GA hopefully
the audience can figure out the blender
here
the bishop check right I'm sure Arjun
can find all the losing moves right uh
yeah that that's just pretty bad and
then so he resigned because of its mate
in ten did you see it
no I just no okay obviously uh and this
is enough so yeah he's just losing his
stuff and it's even word gets made it
really quickly it's wonderful all right
so those are very good games very
exciting and you know you're not afraid
to take sharp risks against high rated
players so it's a lot of fun you have a
point and a half so you are one of the
leaders in the tournament I didn't
consider that to be a risk you can
consider this to be a risk yeah not the
first one either okay
well excellent yeah cuz I mean some
people they see you know 400 points
higher rated than me and they get scared
but uh you know you were declining
drawers and you were playing for the win
so alright fantastic stuff so thanks for
for coming here and sharing your
thoughts with us and until then we'll
see you guys next week